do you know how hard it is to truly
generate random numbers i i don't mean
the random number generator on your
phone or anything like this that's just
algorithm that crunches something but
it's deterministic true random numbers
are super difficult to generate there is
even a wikipedia article about it what
you need to do is you need to measure
some actual physical phenomenon like
atmospheric noise or thermal noise or or
other things that we have no idea they
are so chaotic we just can't predict
them and thus their results are truly
truly random random.org even sells to
random number generators for you this is
big topic humanity has searched for and
wide for truly random processes but now
ladies and gentlemen
we found it the nurip's review process
is a absolutely truly random phenomenon
so if you're not aware a way way time
ago in nurips what was that 2014 the
organizers made a little experiment
where they gave certain set of papers
that was submitted to the conference not
only to one committee to review but the
two separate committees in order to
track how the committees would agree or
disagree now the results right there
were quite damning to be honest so not
only did they not find any sort of
correlation between what the reviewers
scores they gave with any sort of future
citations and that's a paper that i've
covered in a video where they look back
seven years later at whether or not the
reviewers could predict anything about
these papers turns out they cannot they
also found that the reviewers mostly
didn't really agree that much so here
were these experiments now of the
166 papers most were rejected by both
committees which most papers to such a
conference are rejected so reject is
sort of the default answer but here look
at that if committee one accepted and
committee one accepted for 22 plus 21
papers so for 33 papers committee 2 only
agreed on half of them and likewise when
committee 2 accepted for the 43 papers
and this is 44 papers so for the 44
papers that committee 2 accepted
committee one only agreed again in half
of them so this means that if you were
to switch committees for the papers only
half of the accepted papers would be the
same papers half of them would be other
papers that had actually been rejected
by the other committee which is
kind of crazy but this just shows you
how noisy this process really is now
it's 20 21 and we've actually repeated
this experiment so here's a reddit post
by the user wai gua chiang that has
scraped from open review these scores
and put together some statistics such as
this one here that shows the average
rating of the papers versus how many of
papers were in a particular bucket and
what ultimately happened to them so we
only have full data insight into the
accepted papers and the rejected papers
that have sort of voluntarily agreed to
make their reviews public which most
papers that are rejected don't now the
most interesting part here is this one
this is the repetition of the nurip's
experiment you can see at the bottom the
total is almost 300 papers and again
these are not all the papers part of the
experiment these are only the papers
that were accepted because we don't know
anything about the other ones so the way
this worked was the follows papers were
given to two separate committees these
two committees reached a decision
independently of each other and then the
maximum of the two decisions was taken
as an acceptance criterion so if either
of the committees accepted the paper to
be published the paper was going to be
published so to understand this table
the leftmost column is the final
decision which is the max of decision
one and decision two not always but
we'll get to that then the second column
is the decision of the first committee
and the third column is the decision of
the second committee now these things
are ordered so it's not the same as in
the last paper i've shown you so since
there's no clear ordering we simply
always put the larger decision on the
left and the second large decision on
the right so the most interesting part
of this is how many papers were accepted
by one committee but rejected by another
one for that we have to add together all
the rows where one of the decision is a
reject so 174 plus 16 plus 9 is i think
199 papers
199 papers out of the 298 papers that
were accepted had actually been rejected
by a second committee so to compare we
have to do the following we'll say that
essentially the analogy would be that 22
and 22 and 21 papers so 65 papers would
be our analogous total number from down
here those are the papers that
ultimately ended up being accepted
because they were accepted by one of the
committees and then 22 plus 21 papers so
43 papers would be the amount of papers
that would have been rejected by one of
the two committees but ultimately ended
up being accepted because it was
accepted by the other one so according
to this here we see 43 out of 65 papers
only were accepted by one of the
committees and here we see that roughly
200 out of 300 papers were only accepted
by one of the committees in both cases
it's about two-thirds of the paper which
means that actually this is remarkably
consistent so in the face of that and
with the explosion of the machine
learning community more papers more
reviewers and so on you could actually
say it's a good thing it's actually
surprising this hasn't gotten much worse
over the years now that's one way to
look at it and the other way to look at
it is to say this is crap like come on
this is completely inconsistent not only
the accept reject is inconsistent you
see of the six papers suggested to an
oral by one of the committees this was
never confirmed by another committee and
how many were suggested for a spotlight
by one of the committees 16 20 29 41 44
44 papers were suggested for a spotlight
by one of the committees yet only three
had actually both committees agreeing
and again the same results hold if you
were to swap out committees if you just
differently assign people to papers half
of the papers that are in the conference
would be different
half and i don't know how people can
still claim that peer review is like
this esteemed thing that is supposed to
catch errors and do quality control and
yada yada there's something to be said
that if you have a really good paper the
probability that a different committee
also accepts it is is pretty high and
also if you have a really bad paper the
probability that two committees agree on
rejecting it i guess that's even higher
however most papers fall somewhere in
the middle and that's the area of true
randomness essentially what you do is
you throw your paper in there and then
something something happens and then you
get a random number at the end and
remember people use this to justify
archive blackouts social media blackouts
oh my god you cannot buy us the
reviewers you must not buy us the
pristine
review you're you cannot buy us a random
number generator i guess you can but it
makes no makes no sense like honestly
this is only half joking at this point
the social media networks that we have
people surfacing interesting papers from
the depths of archive and from their
social networks all the people filtering
this kind of stuff yes there's promotion
going on yes there's hype yes money
plays a role but still this is a much
better process than just like three
random dudes sitting on the toilet like
scrolling through your paper a bit and
then writing
not enough experiments uh reject i don't
understand it it's confusing look at the
learning rate grafting video i did like
these are the types of reviews that
reviewers have to battle with yes it
hasn't gotten much worse over the years
yes really good papers are consistent
really bad papers are consistent but i
still maintain that this situation is
not really a good one this is absolutely
inconsistent it's a lottery your best
bet is to write as many papers as you
can that are just barely barely not crap
and then throw all of them in and
through the random number process some
of them will get accepted and that's a
sad state because big companies do this
for clout big companies do it to recruit
new people and so on but there are a lot
of phd students that need to get
whatever their three papers published in
their four or five years that they're
doing the phd and with such randomness
and with only very very limited amount
of conferences that you can submit to
over the course of a year there's like
three or four different big conferences
that you realistically can submit to if
you want a good impact factor this is
very bad situation and a lot of people
are going to be damaged just because the
universe has some random fluctuations
the solution to this honestly starts
with professors tenured professors start
handing out phds independent of
conference submissions universities
start giving professors tenure not on
the basis of the impact factor of where
they publish look at citations look at
how popular the work is in any other
metric stop considering impact factors
of conferences grant agencies stop
giving out grants based on the
reputations of the professors based on
the impact factors essentially disregard
conference publications for anything you
do i see some people they have to do it
some professors have to get tenure and
this is a criterion phd students have to
do this because that's a requirement for
their phd but if you're in a position to
discard all of this do it what stops you
you have tenure tell your phd students
do three really nice really good archive
publications if i'm happy with it phd
all right that was it from me for
ranting about this topic what do you
think about it let me know in the
comments maybe i'm completely wrong here
but you know i'm happy to be educated to
the contrary
see ya
[Music]
you